تتوقف عند وضع جهاز الشرطه الاخلاق المثير
للجدل منذ وفاه مهسا امين
تصريحات ربما اضفت الغموض تصريحات المدعي
العام الايراني الفتى الغموض على هذا
الجهاز الامني الذي يقع تحت السلطه الرئيس
ابراهيم
رئيسي بالتالي سالي هل هذا التصريح كانت
السلطات راغبه به في هذا التوقيت ام ان
الامر ليعد مجرد جواب على سؤال المدعي
العام خلال مؤتمر صحفي
تحيه طيبه لك ست وداد ولجميع المشاهدين
طبعا اعتقد يعني حاول الاعلام يعني ان
يعظم الامر وكانما هناك حصل تراجع في
سياسات الحكومه اتجاه قضيه الحجاب
ويعني سمعنا كلام الى ان
الحكومه تراجعت ويعني اوقفت عمل جهاز شرطه
الاخلاق يعني شرطه الاخلاقيه ليست مؤسسه
او جهاز كبير هو لا يعمل فيه الكثير من
المدن يختصر عمله على بعض المدن وخاصه
الكبيره منها العاصمه طهران ولكن هذه لا
ينتمي اليه الكثير من العناصر حتى
السيارات التي يستخدمها الجهاز هي معدوده
جدا يعني هناك من تحدث عن ان لا يتجاوز
عددها في العاصمه سبعه ايام سيارات او على
اكبر قدر عشر السيارات فهو جهاز فقير جدا
له مهام معينه
عيد ربما ربما اهميه هذا الجهاز ليس في
همم ربما عدد عناصره او ربما ال- همم
مؤهلاته او الوسائل التي توضع تحت امرها
بل بقدر ما يقوم به
طبعا يعني نحن امام اليوم قضيه في ايران
هي قضيه في كل بدايه يعني بدات بقضيه يعني
مهسا امينه ولكن اليوم ابتعدنا كثيرا عن
هذه القضيه وصلنا الى يعني الدعوه الى
احتجاجات واعمال شقق طبعا هذه تاثير دعوات
من الخارج
وتريد ان تلهب المجتمع همم داخل ايران
تريد ان تضغط على الحكومه في مقابل ذلك
طبعا هناك سياسات معاكسه من غدا للحكومه
لارشال هذه المساعي تعرفين شكوى يعني هناك
خطوط اقتصادي كبيره علينا
في اثناء اعلنت همم اعتقال اثني عشر شخصا
بتهمه الارتباط ابي عملاء في الخارج بدون
ذكر تفاصيل طبعا همم ربما بدون تدوير هذه
القضيه لكن ما يحصل في الداخل الايراني
ربما يعبر على نوع من ازمات المختلفه التي
يتخبط او تتخبط فيها السلطه في ايران
وانتم تحدثتم عن ربما هذا الوضع الاقتصاد
المتردي وهذي الازمه الاجتماعيه ايضا
اذا ما كانت هناك مشاكل اقتصاديه وبكل
تاكيد توجد مشاكل اقتصاديه ولكن سبب هذا
في الدرجه الاولى هي الضغوط الاقتصاديه
التي تفرضها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولكن هناك يعني خطوات ايجابيه
وملموسه وواضحه يعني بدء المواطن يراها
للحكومه الايرانيه حكومه ابراهيم رئيس
استطاعت ان تصل الى حد بعيد الضغوط
الاقتصاديه هناك تحسن كبير في مستوى
الحياه في مبيعات النفسيه همم الايرادات
والعمله الصعبه اتمنى ادى الى ان تقول
للحكومه قبل يومين انها حصلت على
الميزانيه يعني قبل انتهاء العام ولا توجد
لديها مشاكل الاقتصاديه او ماليه ولكن بكل
تاكيد يعني ظهور مستمر من قبل الخارج
والمساعي لافشان هذه الضغوط ايضا مستمره
من قبل الاخيره
بالعوده الى جهاز همم شرطه هدا يعني ان
وضعه باطل
يعني شو اسمه هذا هو الاهم من الجهاز شرطه
الاخلاق هي قضيه الحجاب قضيه الحجاب طبعا
هنا مدعومه من قبل الشارع بشكل كبير وايضا
هي يعني نفس في الدستور ولكن لا ننكر ان
هناك همم لا يعني لا توافق على الحجاب كما
اا هو في ح- يعني بشكل الحالي سوري يعني
تقرير في هذا البند واللي يعني الحديث من
الجهتين مستمر
ينبغي ان ماذا سيحدث في هذه القضيه على
المستقبل